a very good time to grow up in San
Francisco was a wonderful place we lived
in the city my father was a lawyer for
the San Francisco school board I still
have his watch it's his watch it says
Irving brighter use San Francisco
Unified School District 1933 to 1973 he
was born in San Francisco his father
moved there and I guess before the turn
of the 20th century my mother was from
st. Paul she'd moved out I had one
brother was younger and San Francisco is
a as I say a wonderful place because it
was you could very easily get to the
mountains or you I was in the Boy Scouts
I love the Boy Scouts we go on hiking
trips I we could you could go across the
bay the weather was good and I don't
think we realized how lucky we were it
didn't take a lot of money really didn't
and today I guess you'd have to have a
lot of money to live the way we lived in
without burning